goody we can grow giant models for foot
in a month the 45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model nice and tender -
some of them look a bit tough but once
you cut into them they cut like butter
my name is Philip vowels I live in San
Ari Wales and I grow giant vegetables
I've been growing giant vegetables now
for the last 30 years I come from a very
large family
my mother had 17 children 13 of us
survived and I think you know that was
something you know big vegetables feed
big families you know I'm a p.m. every
morning every night every single day of
the week there's a lot of love and cake
was into it sometimes I do able to talk
into them as well to encourage them to
grow which is a bit of a bit of fun you
know I think he's just about finished
grow in there now I got to be very
careful the wife is not about when I
start talking to my vegetables but it's
all good fun I broke the world record
for the heaviest cucumber what 25 years
ago it radiates in a half pound and it
was just incredible the way do you know
when I started if we had a morrow 20 30
pound in weight you are the base model
now we're up over and repelling weight
normal cabbage would be two pounding
weights while we are growing I'm 120
pounds you know you can feed 120 and 240
people off one cabbage this is why I
supply the local pub and they use a
mapper Sunday lunch I've developed my
own strain more or less now I select my
own seed every year the biggest and the
best seed and it just seems to be
improving which is incredible
I grow organically I just think if I can
do it anybody can do it and it's a big
thrill every day the wife say what am i
doing up a lot whatever II day and when
she comes up she realized